What is that is that my tail hair!
welcome back everyone this will be my marvel
groot episodes video i'll just do a single
video for all the episodes because they
were short so i'll explain what's going on
where i am groot fits in the timeline and what's
going on during guardians of the galaxy 3.
if you're new to the channel she-hulk episodes
start next week i'll be doing videos for all the
episodes so be sure to subscribe to get those i'll
be doing a special marvel giveaway during that
i'll start by doing the disney plus membership
giveaway all you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and just leave your favorite moment
from the i am groot episodes there were five
episodes total most of the episodes like
everything except for the first episode were
mostly meant to take place after the events of
guardians of the galaxy 2 like right after the
end of the movie but before the post-credits
scene where he grows the teenage groot
so if it wasn't clear there was a bit of a time
jump between the different episodes like the
first episode takes place much earlier in the
timeline like before guardians of the galaxy
2 picks up all the other episodes mostly take
place right after the ending of guardians of
the galaxy 2 because they have that portion of
the eclector the ravager's mothership that's
still intact the one that they stole and they
blew up the rest of the ship when they took off
this will also be relevant for what's happening
during guardians of the galaxy 3 with the ravagers
i'll talk about this at the end of the video
too because during guardians of the galaxy 3
when things pick up the younger version of gamora
that's left over from 2014 that came to the past
she's actually taken over the ravagers and they're
finding out for the first time in the trailer they
released at comic con like what you're in charge
of the ravagers now apparently star-lord has not
been checking his messages since the events of
thor love and thunder are since avengers end game
because during the trailer they very clearly
reference that they themselves are also ravagers
like all the guardians are ravagers and there's a
whole bunch of other huge deep cut easter eggs in
that trailer so i did a separate video for it i'll
add the link for that at the end of this and down
in the description below so you can learn more
about what's happening in the guardians of the
galaxy 3 trailer but the title of episode 1 was
groot's first steps it's a reference to baby groot
growing out of his pot for the first time as
like a really tiny baby and actually taking his
first steps vin diesel did come back to do all the
episodes he also voiced all the baby groot scenes
during guardians of galaxy 2. like he basically
does all of groot's voices and he just changes
his voice to sound whatever age groot needs to
be bradley cooper also came back to do the new
rocket scenes too so he is the voice of rocket
instead of them getting another voice actor the
reason they had a rocket come in these episodes
instead of one of the other guardians is also
because he sort of become baby groot's surrogate
father or teenage groups or a good father however
you want to think about them depending on where
you are on the timeline james gunn even revealed
that during avengers infinity war when everyone is
getting snapped by thanos and groot is starting to
disappear he's starting to get dusted he cries
out father to rocket he said that when they're
filming guardian scenes he'll actually translate
groot's dialogue for the other actors but he won't
reveal to anyone besides the actors what groot
is actually saying every once in a while he'll
reveal details like that like during this avengers
infinity war scene where he's literally calling
rocket his father during the opening titles baby
groot sand reaches out breaking the fourth wall a
little bit as if he's watching the marvel logo
play himself speeding it up using the remote
control up to double speed with the sound pitched
away up high the closest we've actually come to
that in the mcu is in the deadpool and korg video
which is kind of in the mcu but not in the mcu
where he watches a ryan reynolds movie with korg
in character she-hulk is another character who
broke the fourth wall in the comics and they
actually brought that back for the she-hulk
series so she's gonna be breaking the wall a bunch
deadpool style but technically she did it in the
comics before deadpool so technically deadpool is
the person copying her breaking the fourth wall
when it slows down and you actually see the logo
play it's sort of like the animated logo that they
use for the what-if episodes and they end with
a joke about him knocking over the screen that
he's watching it on so it looks like the logo
falls over within picking up over the frame the
way they play this first episode it takes place
in the past like i said with a montage of super
tiny baby groot just growing out big enough to
make it out of his pot for the first time we
didn't actually see that happen in the time jump
between guardians 1 and guardians of the galaxy 2.
so like the events of this episode will be taking
place really soon after the events of guardians
of the galaxy 1 because guardians of the galaxy 2
took place pretty close to the events of guardians
1 so he grew out of his pop pretty fast with them
just playing it for a joke here like he literally
crashes out of his pot like he accidentally
breaks his pot and that's how he gets out
also turns out there's a lot of support drones
around the guardians of the galaxy ship the
benetar in the ravager ship the eclector
r.i.p to that bonsai tree which he pretty
much destroys he pretty much destroys everybody
in every single episode sometimes inadvertently
sometimes on purpose like baby groot is hardcore
turns out also if it wasn't clear they clarified
that this version of groot is sort of like the
offspring of the original groot as opposed to
the comics in the comics group can just regrow
himself from a single twig but the way that james
gunn wants this version of groot to be he's more
like the offspring of the original groot he's not
like a tiny version of the original groot it's
like a whole different groot during the guardians
of the galaxy 3 trailer though it does look like
he finally hooks out like he has his own version
of a groot hulk out moment where he grows to full
groove size and vin diesel called him alpha groot
during guardians of the galaxy 3 like the most
version of groot the title of episode 2 is the
little guy which is a reference to both baby groot
being a little guy literally in the grun's race of
aliens who he winds up destroying almost which are
tiny compared to him they have the same star wars
phantom menace prequels meme at the beginning
a big joke about there always being a bigger
fish with like the giant furry alien coming to eat
him but then it being captured by the larger bird
and then groot finding the tiny gruns the gruns
are actually an alien race from the comics they
debuted in the classic defenders comics which
is a big coincidence because like daredevil is
coming back a lot of these defenders characters
already exist but the defender's version in the
comics was very different from the defender's
netflix version of the team like hulk was on the
original defenders team where the grun's debuted
interesting coincidence because we're seeing hulk
next week in the she-hulk episodes and apparently
baby groot farts leaves i guess that makes sense
good to know he also probably craps trash bags
full of yard clippings never really thought about
it that way till now but like we literally see
baby groot on the toilet like he's on the can
in episode three and they just turn this into
a big joke about him accidentally killing this
whole race or thinking that he killed the race but
then they kind of take the joke back at the end
revealing that they survived i think so he doesn't
come off as quite so psychopathic but the thing
about that though is that he winds up throwing
the alien in episode three out the airlock killing
it any winds up ripping the fur off the other
squirrel alien in episode four that probably hurt
pretty bad a lot of these jokes with the gruns
just being this highly advanced but super tiny
race like their weapons seem pretty advanced even
though they don't hurt groot that much is a lot
like the rick and morty tiny verse episode where
he literally uses an alien race that's like super
tiny that lives inside his battery to power his
spaceship like you people are nothing to me you're
my battery episode 3 is titled groot's pursuit
it's a reference to the water-based life form that
groot finds and chases down its name is the iwua
it's not from the comics but there are water-based
life forms kind of like this in the comics they
finally confirmed that he's on the eclector during
the events of this episode like i said this is
taking place after the end of guardians of the
galaxy 2 but before the post-credits scene and he
just finds a broken canister with this alien that
apparently the ravagers have stolen are going to
try and sell off to someone else it's a little on
the nose but he is wearing christmas tree themed
pajamas because he is literally a tree based life
form the wrist watch that he finds seems like a
human watches program with alien lettering on it
and when it starts spouting off all the workout
jokes later in the episode when he starts
hitting it i think that's just a reference to star
lord's bowflex jokes during avengers infinity war
like it's just jokes about star-lord trying to
stay in shape the book that he winds up reading on
the can is apparently about thanos and a bunch of
other aliens apparently there's a bunch of merch
out there around the galaxy around the universe
with thanos on it like it's a very common thing
you also notice on the cover this same bird alien
was the one that tried to eat him in the previous
episode he and the alien wind up having their own
dance-off like the end of the first guardians of
the galaxy movie like a super-sized version
of that after which he just gets bored of it
and sends him right at the airlock so i hope
his race can survive in the vacuum of space
but like i said baby groot is hardcore episode
four is titled groot takes a bath it's just a
reference to groot gaining all the extra power
when he stays in that special alien water like
it's somehow a little bit different from regular
water and gives him this extra power up that just
causes him to grow uncontrollably i think he could
do a lesser version of this if he had access to a
body of water like if he were in a fight and he
needed an extra power up and he were standing in
water it would give him a little extra juice so to
speak the only thing about this though is that i
never really thought of baby groot as being smart
enough to make himself like a spa-level bat this
seems pretty complicated him putting this together
because during guardians of the galaxy too they
make him seem pretty simple-minded like he had a
lot of trouble just understanding what they wanted
him to steal i don't think he gained a normal
level of intellect until he became teenage groot
i actually kind of thought because he killed
the alien in the last episode throwing him at
the airlock that he killed this squirrel alien
too but he just ripped the fur right off of him
so i guess it's a form of mercy but you have to
imagine that him ripping the fur off of a creature
would hurt really bad the last episode episode
5 is titled magnum opus is just a reference to
the painting of the guardians of the galaxy that
he tries to make using items that he steals from
all over the ship you notice the jansport backpack
in the alf comic book those are both from the 80s
because they're both star-lord's belongings from
when he was a child like some of his belongings
from the 80s has survived like ego the living
planet smashed his tape player in his awesome
mix that his mother had given him but some of
his stuff has still survived present day he
steals some of rocket's tail fur circuit boards
from the ship drax's soap some of the stuff is
actually really critical components like he steals
some of the fuel cells that rocket has stolen from
the sovereign setting off the whole atom warlock
plot in guardians of the galaxy too this is what
will poulter's atom warlock actually looks like
in guardians of the galaxy 3 in that trailer from
comic-con he actually looks like he's going to
be pretty badass that isn't the soul gem in his
forehead that's just like something different it's
probably kind of like a white vision situation
where white vision doesn't have the mind stone
anymore he has like a different power crystal
that's replaced it this is star-lord's boot with
the rockets on them him detonating the explosion
is also just another callback to him hitting
that bomb that blew up ego the living planet
then bradley cooper's rocket shows up like i said
it is bradley cooper coming back to voice new
dialogue after which he gets thrown at the airlock
almost also turns out rocket wears eyeglasses
i've already done a much larger video for the
guardians of the galaxy 3 comic con trailer so
i'll add a link below in the description and
at the end of this so you can re-watch that
but the whole idea with guardians 3 is that it's
more about rockets origin story we got a little
taste of that in the first guardians film like
he's from half world he was created by the high
evolutionary the high evolutionary in the mcu
is going to be played by chukwudi iwuji from the
peacemaker series so a lot of you will recognize
them from peacemaker they pulled a full-on loki at
the marvel comic-con panel where he came dressed
as the high evolutionary in full character as if
he were the actual character it was actually
pretty cool call me sia okay i'm pleased
to be here as i gaze out at this crowd i'm
reminded of my sole purpose in the universe
to take unevolved disgusting
low-life scum such as yourselves
and enhance you genetically to something less
reprehensible the other big thing is also
star-lord trying to win over the new version of
gamora because like she doesn't know him from adam
doesn't have any kind of relationship with him so
he's trying to bring her into the family and it's
also about the relationship between nebula and
gomorrah so whereas in the first movie gamora
was trying to sort of free nebula from thanos
influence now it's kind of the other way around
with nebula trying to be the one to win over
gamora because like at the beginning of guardians
of the galaxy 3 nebula has gone full thanos like
she's a way more hardcore version of the character
that's taken over the ravagers we can all lay our
bets on which of the guardians we think james gunn
is going to kill during this movie my bet right
now is on rocket maybe drax too cosmo the space
dog is gonna be a much bigger character during
the movie and obviously like the big thing is them
doing a version of adam warlock james glenn also
said that it's going to be the last marvel movie
with this roster of the guardians of the galaxy
but not the end of the guardians of the galaxy so
my theory right now is that adam warlock is going
to join the team beta ray bill joined a version of
the team in the comics but we've only seen him
in the background of marvel movies so we'll see
if they actually wind up actually doing beta ray
bill at some point too the only real big cosmic
characters right now that i'm waiting for is like
an mcu version of the phoenix force silver surfer
in galactus but everybody post all your theories
in the comments below and if you spotted any other
easter eggs during the i am groot short episodes
just write them below in the comments i'll do more
guardians of the galaxy 3 videos as we get more
footage we'll probably get a full trailer either
later this year or early next year and they're
going to have a disney plus day in september which
is going to be like trailer fest it'll be like the
disney plus day last year where they released all
the marvel disney plus trailers and the star wars
disney plus trailers so like that's probably when
we'll get the mandalorian season 3 trailer wait
wait for everything everyone click here for my
full guardians of the galaxy 3 trailer video and
click here for my brand new she-hulk daredevil
trailer thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!